gang baby
gang baby
gang
triple gang but we out here triple
ganging
getting ready for gangs giving son
um happy day to everybody happy day to
everybody
I hope somebody hope I hope you woke up
today and and somebody loved you
and you know who I really hope that I
hope I hope
I hope it was yourself
because that's the car that's the kicker
you know I meet a stranger off you know
I'll hug them
you have somebody that you know [ __ ]
I'll dang hug I'll hug a dang hitchhiker
you know I'll put if if there was a
hitchhiker and he put his hands in his
pockets I'd put my hand in his pockets
at the same time
just play Hot Pocket in there no no no
rubbing or nothing just be there with
him
you know because you don't know a
hitchhiker until you've
you know walked a day or
handed a mile in his pockets you know
it's like I'm just saying it could be a
hitchhiker and I'll go Rusty and I'll
you know I'll hug him I'll hug him fast
because they're dirty they got a lot of
that Interstate dust you know
a lot of um those big trucks throw up a
bunch of dirt
and if you're right there hiking baby a
lot of it damn get lodged on you
you'll have a sand dune of just
of just cigarette Ash and Interstate
dirt just Lodge don't you know in the in
the
in the uh crevasse of your neck
if you are out there hitchhiking
but you know I'm amazed sometimes that
my ability to be
loving towards strangers
but then lacking that same
um
that same compassion for myself or
sometimes for people that are close to
me
you know it's like I'll give us you know
I'll take my chances on a stranger
the devil's Rose Shambo baby a
hitchhiker
I'll take my chances out there
before I'll do uh before I'll easily ex
you know
um
what are we talking about
oh loving before I'll be loving to to
someone who is already close to me or is
Bill is my family a lot of times it's
been in my past
and that's not my present
uh
but it has been my past
um
anyway not not a downer there just
interesting and it's that time of year
you know to really
you know it's that damn time of year to
damn
I mean kiss grandma
kiss that [ __ ] in the kitchen you know
just
and I don't even look if she's had a
glass of wine put a damn blindfold on
Grandma and damn kiss her
put it say look
what was Grandpa's favorite song put
that [ __ ] on
and lock owner you don't be perving out
on her
don't be trying to touch all in her slip
or or uh
you know we're a damn split a thing a
dent team with her whatever uh
evident or whatever it's called effer
dent
don't try to don't be
don't get old
pervacious but I think look if you wanna
put on your sneak on your Granddaddy's
favorite shirt if he's passed away I
mean
and put a blindfold on Grandma slow
dance in the kitchen
let her put her head on your chest just
be that say hey
I know you missed Grandpa let me could I
slow dance with you for a minute
no touch and I just want you to
put a little Old Spice in that little
make you a little Pond of you know where
your clavicle makes that little Pond
right there
on your neck
if you're hungry if you leaned out you
can get that little you make your little
puddle right there
put your little Old Spice in that [ __ ]
and get Grandma out there in the kitchen
dance with her
do something for somebody you know
that's what I want to do
little things see my sister give her a
hug
text my brother in the morning tell him
tell him I love him no reason at all
just a simple this simple fact that he
that he graced my heart that the idea of
him that he visited just my brain
you know it's not it's you know
so I hope yeah I hope you and not
everybody has a family member and I hope
that you do have somebody
that you that you love or that loves you
or that you're able to love yourself on
this holiday time
because we need it and it's tough and it
is what it is baby
um
but I'm so grateful to be sitting here
with you and uh we got a nice little
episode here and um
and yeah I'm just feeling full man I'm
feeling full of Hope
as much as I don't want to be sometimes
I don't want to be hopeful
you know there's a part of there's a
part of me sometimes don't want to be
hopeful
you won't see me down there by the Hope
pond
putting hope meat on my hope hook
and just hoping I catch something you
want so I don't want to be hopeful
sometimes
sometimes I'd rather be a curmudgeon
yes Mom I'm just talking in four-wheel
drive everything
my boy I got a V10 in my my throat
my diesel I got diesel tonsils
and I'm just every I want to be here
because it's been it's hard sometimes to
be hopeful
it's hard if you feel like life has
burnt you a little
if you feel like the past wasn't what it
was supposed to be for you you don't
want to be hopeful anymore
you want to have that chip on your
shoulder
you want to be a shoulder chip baby
out there chip chopping
and just slanging chips off your
shoulder step right up who needs a chip
huh chips on one shoulder dip on the
other
you're just a damn little condiment
you're just a little damn appetizer at
that point
but yeah I'm more willing I feel like
these days to try and be hopeful
just be hopeful
I didn't want to be hopeful because it's
hard it's if I admit
to the world that I'm willing to have
hope
then that means I'm stop then that means
I'm not willing to hold a grudge
and I sometimes I don't know if I'm I'm
willing to let go of one of them enough
to grow to to to grab onto that other
one because that's where you got to have
some faith in there when you're letting
go with the grudges
to grasp onto the hope there's some
space in there
and that's man it's the shortest bit of
space but damn that is hard
it's hard to get it's hard to get from
one to the other
it's hard to let go of those that pad
that those things that are because they
give me power oh I'm angry about this
[ __ ] this [ __ ] these people on that and
that I don't know I remember them
that all gives me a gives me something I
well I can always preach at them
but man if I want to let go of that
and reach for that hope baby damn that
things could be different
and open myself up to opportunity it's
been hard for me to do in my life but
today I'm hopeful
that I'm on to something new
come on baby
thank you for being here with me today I
love you
whenever you're down out in the cold
faithless and die your story is Untold
come take my hand and walk there with me
I know a place where we can be free
there is a light shining for you
guiding your way
helping you through Shadows
[Music]
where we can
[Music]
from the mountains
[Music]
Freak come on baby
[Music]
there we go and we got into that
and I'm something you got to get into it
baby sometimes
you gotta get down in there
you gonna get in there
which bam boy someone you got man
someone wish I could just just
completely hide myself inside of my nuts
don't you God
cause I'll say this about nuts people
say this and that about nuts oh them
nuts are nasty
you hear women say that oh look at them
nasty nuts he got them old you know he
got them old 1990s nuts or whatever
or you'll hear us how he got them um
look at these cheap nuts some woman said
that to me once
about my nuts I'm like what
it's like yeah with your cheap ass nuts
and then she hit my nuts like that dude
and you know if you have nuts one
quarter if you have a quarter square
inch of pressure on your nuts bro
if a damn Acorn falls off a seven inch
Tree in Lansing or another bro it's
going to hurt
because your nuts is damn oh they are
insecure
I'll say that
your nuts are insecure that's just what
they are
but um
but I'll say this the skin on your nuts
damn come on
actually that's a damn beaut that's a
nice material
there's no doubt if I had a couple of
damn
um
some damn ball skin loafers or something
to put my feet in while I watch
television
him oh boy
if I had some damn uh just some dang um
you know find me some some nut wall
slippers in there damn a little bit of
sheepskin on the outside nut wall on the
inside
of a pair of dang Christmas slippers
whoo
Santa's coming on my feet boo boo
you ain't stopping me then
you ain't stopping me in baby if I had a
damn nut coat
if somebody said damn what you wearing
boy me
nut
damn that's 80 nut
20 boss baby
if I'm out now I guess some people would
get the nut skin uh jacket or say if you
couldn't afford it I'd get the vest
because if you show up to a party baby
and you damn you've just vested out in
some just sheer ball skin
if you're wearing sheer ball
if you were in a sheer damn ball vest
and that bitch's gonna be nice
people when they gonna invite you in the
back room to smoke you a joint or
something or get you some bubbly back
there where they keep the good stuff you
know
because that's how it goes it's like at
a party you go to somebody's party and
everybody's having the normal amounts of
things in the living room and it's hey
come back over here if you doing well at
the party
if you're socially acceptable or you're
being you know enjoyable or you're
dancing well or whatever you brought a
couple Dames with you and they say come
over here to the back room
and it could be anything if it's just an
eating party it might be somebody invite
you to the back room and they got you
know just a damn little jar of homemade
molasses and they just spooning people
out
get you a little half ounce you know get
Debbie a little half ounce
but if they got drugged and it could be
drugs you know
hey get you a little sack of this get
your little gram of this give Tiffany a
little bit of this oh Ron likes them
uppers
make sure you up or Ron
you know it's just uh
but if you're wearing down nuts boy Come
On Son now the tough part is if you got
cheap ball skin
you got that [ __ ] you know you'd have
different grades of it
you'd have no hair that you'd have to go
probably no hair I think
but I don't know bro you show up with
some damn Middle Eastern nuts skin coat
or little even just a
dude if you had a damn nut skin neck
brace that [ __ ] would be expensive
and if I had that hair on it you got to
keep the hair off of it I think
I don't think I would want that
and then the different grades of it are
the ages
you're like damn they got this [ __ ] off
a 95 year old that's
you know
and then it's like oh this is Dan you
know this is some good 45 you know
somebody unfortunately passed away maybe
cancer or
um
I don't know then this is where this
whole theory is getting a little bit
dark I'm seeing that
but dang boy you telling me I don't show
up
with some Uggs made out of Dick jug skin
come on baby the devil's chicken nuggets
baby nuts
nuts
Satan's tonsils baby you know what I'm
talking about nuts uh
you're nuts
but God forbid I roll up with a damn nut
skin belt fresh nut
like damn look at that thing
and I would even I'd go down probably
off a you know I don't want to say off
it but off a Asian probably a brother
depends on who you know what kind of
what you're going for
because you could do some basic
Caucasian nut but I don't know anyway
this is getting a little dark it's
getting a little dark
Oh Happy Thanksgiving is what I'm trying
to say
and Happy Thanksgiving to you
um
I am uh we got some new stuff it's that
time of year we got some new items if
you want to get somebody a gift you can
check out the hitter hunting club
collection now available at
theovanstore.com
we got hoodies and orange and maroon and
a couple different items over there
uh if you'd like to get out in the woods
we want you to feel like you can take uh
this past weekend with you
so we're grateful for that we got camo
hats
um if you like eating Thanksgiving with
your family but you want to hide from
them at the same time
because I've seen that man we got you
know
you'll have a guy who don't even want to
be around his family that much and so
he'll be in a damn deer blind in his
house
if you love a guy in there in complete
camouflage in his own at his own dinner
table
you're like Hey Dad please pass the uh
the payers
and he picks a pair off his dang his
camo because he have like the the camo
he got was cheaper I had like a tropical
vibe to it
and so you know it's got Pine and like
some you know bark but then it also have
a couple damn fruit trees in it bro you
know
like damn this camo is a little you know
this camo don't this is that San
Francisco camo you know what I'm saying
well have a damn fruit tree in that
[ __ ]
some of his kill have a damn bird feeder
on like damn this camo really it's some
three-dimensional camo
and he'll damn pick a pair and pass it
over to his son at the dinner table
because they're having trouble
communicating and a man can't keep in
touch with his own family
um
I don't know what I'm talking about and
I never have I never really have
and uh and you guys have always been
supportive of me for that or while I've
done that and thank you thank you so
much
um
I am
I'm feeling better
it's scary to say that a little bit but
I'm feeling better
um even just moments like today where
I'm able to sit here
and not feel too overwhelmed uh
and just man I'm just grateful I'm
grateful for um
the people that have been coming out to
shows I'm grateful for the community
we've had
um
I'm looking forward we're trying to get
a new studio it's not going to look
completely different okay we're just
trying to get a new facility
um a little bit because this one is
we're right close by the elevator
I mean we are I mean that [ __ ] is is
right there
so you can
you know if somebody's going I can hear
somebody picking their nose in that
meant
so we don't want you know we just and it
rattled we just want to get and the
bathrooms are right there so it's like
you can hear people in there
if some dudes gassed up or he got that
body gas or that booty puff on him
you know if he's burping out his ass
um we can hear it
you know the valet guy they got one dude
he says he's valet but he's not he just
it's just a it's just a dude that gets
angry at people for parking so that's
not
that's kind of just an [ __ ] kinda
but he uh he got a bad GI tract on him
I mean he gots a damn
that dude's got some humidity in his
butt because he'll you hear him in there
just cat foreign in there he'll be up
there
I mean the weather channels show up when
this dude hits the throne baby he's in
there butting out in there doing booty
spraying large baby praise God bless him
but
I don't want to be right here on him
you know I feel like a middle man
sometimes between him and the rest you
know because you hear him in their damn
Trumpet of the Swan he's in there
you know he's in there he's in the damn
uh in the Philharmonic in that [ __ ]
he's in there playing that booty
harmonica dude tooting you know what I'm
saying fighting
um but we'll get into the episode uh
I'm gonna let you know a couple of dates
we got
um Louisville Indianapolis Shreveport
Louisiana Baton Rouge Corpus Christi
Texas
uh Helston Houston Texas Houston Texas
Houston my bad
the H they had lowercase H here
uh Phoenix Arizona New York City New
York
you know when they say it twice like
that in the title just because they're
you know they're just [ __ ] that's
just how it you know well hey Welcome to
New York City New York I I heard you the
first time guy uh you know I heard you I
we both heard you you heard you too you
heard you
um and then Austin Texas
those are all dates from January 25th to
June 3rd all those are at theovan.com
t-o-u-r please make sure you go through
theovan.com tour because you're going to
get accurately priced
what else happened oh we went to San
Diego that was amazing uh thank you
everybody for coming out over there I
was in I got real sick man I had a flu
that hit me
I had a flu that hit me and um
so man we were getting bag after bag
after bag just getting um
IVs and stuff in the back and
the lady that came to give the eye she
was kind of watch she was cool but she
also she would just she'd throw anything
in that bag in the IV bag that thing had
down
you know it had vitamins and then that
[ __ ] put them
I think she put a thing of Crystal Light
in there the little like damn
I don't know if I can do Crystal Light
to my veins you know she'd be putting
everything in that [ __ ]
you know little
however she put you know couple she put
two out about two hours and 20 minutes
of a Five Hour Energy she poured that
[ __ ] right into the bag I like damn bro
you could hear my heart it sounded like
it hit a speed bumps
[Music]
dang bro that's you pouring anything in
that [ __ ]
and one of the shows I got I couldn't
even barely see out of my eyes man my
eyes weren't doing good in my ears I
couldn't all my senses were getting I
thought you know my senses were kind of
getting phased out
kind of like Elon Musk worked for my
senses and he's like all right we
cutting two of these [ __ ] off baby
we cutting two of these [ __ ] off
um
what else I hope you're doing something
good for Thanksgiving I'm gonna head
down to uh Louisiana
um I'm hoping to get to see friends and
family down there and
um
I'm really looking forward to that
um
what else has been going on San Diego
was really amazing you know it was just
you know I hadn't been out there in a
while and so just to get back on stage
[Music]
um
one of the shows was so we're pretty
late it started late and so that was
hectic but thank you to everybody for
all your patience
um
the Thursday and Sunday shows were
amazing the weekend I don't know oh one
night there was a
they had a security guard somebody was
doing something some lady kept showing
her tits right
and I'm you know
I want to see him
you know call me whatever you know titty
boy or something but I want to see you
know
hey look at these tits and she hit them
tits boy I'm like damn
and I knew right when she showed the
tits my tongue just came out and went
like this
and I it was just nothing this
it was like a damn reaction
it was a reaction bruh
like my tongue yeah
like my tongue was waving at them just
just came out of my mouth
like just you know
and so but she kept showing them
and I didn't you know they was decent
before you know I was probably 40 yards
from them
and I love a Ted at more I like a tit
more at probably
zero to a half yard that's my favorite
space for a tit and then I like a tit a
little further out probably at about
four yards out
but that's my favorite spacing where I
like a tit
you know probably zero to a half yard or
about four yards out
and uh
and then she kept shouting just saying
you know screaming so we had it we had
to get her out of there and then the
security guard I asked him
and he acted like I didn't even exist
this guy he had a mask on and he had
like those fake uh contact lenses you
know like the ones that are like
you know it's almost like somebody looks
like they work at like uh they put those
contact lenses in it's like they work at
the like
it's almost like Satan like knows
somebody in their family and they've
been recruited for Satan like Satan's
recruiting and they've been reading the
pamphlets at night at their house
you know what I'm talking about when
they get those crazy eye things they
don't look real a little bit
um but anyway I don't even know what I'm
talking about now uh so that was kind of
wild
um but thank you to everybody for your
support uh
where else did we go that was amazing
well we just got so many new spots
coming up
and and we'll put up new places people
are like are you coming to the angling
you coming to uh New Zealand yes we'll
come to all of them
but time has a way where it doesn't let
you do it all at one time
you know time is a
time is a single file line really
and um
and I can only be in the line in one
place at a time so we'll get there
though and I'm looking forward to it and
we'll get to everywhere we're going to
get to everywhere in America we're going
to do it all
you know I want to come over there to um
St George Utah my brother lives out over
there I want to get over there and be
able to see him and do a show we want to
get up to Portland
NorCal SoCal Mako Mexico dude I want to
go to Mexico and I want to damn bring
some damn illegal aliens in or illegal
immigrants or whatever you want to call
it Elite you know non-legals I don't
know what they call them now
uh but I def I want to meet a couple of
them [ __ ]
and even race them I'll [ __ ] race
them [ __ ] the last hundred yards I
bet I could beat somebody
I'd love to see who they got on their
team
you know it's never too early to play
holiday music I know that oh I played
out I played it in January I'm you know
that I'm the guy who had uh if I'm doing
karaoke
I sang
um
Rocking around the Christmas tree at the
Christmas party hop
because that's who I am people are
pissed at first but then they know the
words and it's a short song and they're
not that pissed
man escaped
if you don't want to piss people off get
them something from manscaped do that
Little Drummer Boy a favor and use the
lawnmower 4.0 to avoid another silent
night in the bedroom it is nice if you
chimp if you trim your bird up
if you trim that peacock boy then you
make sure he's feathered up the manscape
Platinum package 4.0 is the One Stop
Shop for the man who deserves it all it
has everything needed to help you Deck
the Halls from face to balls from the
past hit them up just in time for
mistletoe season get 20 off in free
shipping at manscape.com Theo that's 20
off with free shipping at manscape.com
Theo manscaped get your jingle balls
ready for the holidays you know there's
a lot of hidden costs out there knock
knock who's there hidden costs the
Michael Myers of financial agreements
may be hidden costs
that's why uh credit consolidation from
light stream can help you pay off your
credit cards and lock in a low fixed
interest rate
start at 7.99 APR with autopay and
excellent credit
from light stream you can get a loan
from five thousand to one hundred
thousand and there are absolutely no
fees that's right you can even get your
money as soon as the day that you apply
so if you have different loans here and
there and they're not Consolidated I
certainly think it's a good idea to look
in to that get the consolidation know
what percentages you're paying
and make the best choice for yourself
you could go from paying 400 a month to
300 that's an extra 1200 a year
just for our listeners apply now to get
a special interest rate discount and
save even more the only way to get this
discount is to go to lightstream.com
t-h-e-o that's
l-i-g-h-t-s-t-r-e-a-m.com slash Theo
subject to credit approval rates range
from 7.99 APR to 19.99 APR and include
0.5 zero percent auto pay discount
lowest rates require excellent credit
terms and conditions apply and offers
are subjects to change without notice
visit lightstream.com
t-h-e-o for more information what else
is happening I went on a date
I went on a date
uh so that's cool
you know I'm trying to be more I've been
more Brave like Brave recently about
trying to be uh
uh just trying to
take Dayton a little bit more seriously
a little
um
you know uh
you know I've spent a lot of time in the
in that space in my life not
being serious or not being able to be
serious
so
this will be a little bit different you
know I went on a date and it was just
simple
you know
but I felt like it was manageable and I
just tried to be just have a decent time
not try to put that pressure on it
you know not try to put that boot you
know that body pressure that booty
pressure that smooch pressure none of
that
just hey who are you who am I
let's be right here
let's Tango right here let's let's play
Pickleball with these minutes and hours
let's spend a little bit of time
together
you know your serve my serve your serve
my serve
you know love love maybe or maybe just
game match and that's it and just go on
um
what else
um
I'm trying to think of what else has
been happening in my life where I
where you know things that I could share
or
um I'm seven months sober
so that's exciting
I know there's a lot of people out there
that uh struggle we get a lot of calls
on the hotline and
um try to return some of them when I can
um
but I want you to know if you are trying
to do something different in your life
um
that I can relate to you that's that's
the thing that you and I probably have
in common the most
is that you are trying
I'm always trying to do something
different in my life now that doesn't
mean there's something always wrong with
me
um
but I do always want to have some kind
of improvement you know uh
and I want to get my place self to a
place where I can operate pretty
comfortably
um and sometimes you know that can take
some effort really
so but uh if that's anything like you
then I bet we really have that in common
[Music]
what else
trying to think of what else happened
oh well
I don't know if I talked about it
you know Caleb Presley faked his own
death on me
and
and he well he almost died and so at
least
you know
he's willing to put his muerto where his
mouth is you know so that at least I
respected that but
what happened was he was in the hot heat
something happened to him I don't know
what happened to him he had a you know
he could have some bad salad I don't
know maybe he
you know
he lost too many bets on bar well you
know he I don't know what happened to
him but he I think he you know he lost
probably a couple hundred bucks on North
Carolina
and next thing you know he's in the
hospital he's on a ventilator
and so I'm on an airplane I'm flying on
an airplane somewhere and uh
and I get a damn
um
I get a
a message from Will Compton if you're
not familiar with Will Compton he
um
he is a member of blessing with the boys
and they are a
they're kind of a
um
avant-garde or whatever it's called I
think or one of them is an avant-garde
Taylor there's two of them will and
Taylor are the two men that are on it
and
will yeah Will is like a
Taylor is like an avant-garde he's like
a
football tackle and he
he also looks like he would be like the
like one of the Final Bosses at like
kind of like a Renaissance fair
but like
with a little bit of a Paxon Vibe thrown
in right
and then will is kind of like he's like
this
he only he's like a crash chest dummy
for CTE kind of he's like basically he's
that dog you know they're both dogs
they're both dogs
but will
um will text to me I'm on this airplane
and he said did you hear what happened
to Caleb and when somebody says that
you're like it's two options
either Caleb
is
unalive
or
or whoever the person is that person is
either un alive or they won the lottery
or something right
so I'm like I don't think Caleb even
plays the Powerball or nothing so
I'm like what happened you know he makes
you do the what happened like gee and
I'm on a plane so it's like takes four
minutes I have to restart my phone get
it back on the thing
and it said that he passed away
so I'm sitting in the plane man I start
just breaking down you know
um
I'm just you know
I'm shook
and I even told the guy next to me you
know I mean he could see something was
kind of wrong and I looked over
and I said um
my friend just passed away
and
he goes do you want to go pee that's
what he said
and I'm like what kind of sick dude is
this guy think I am that if somebody
dies
that I gotta go hold my dick for some
reason or you know like
he didn't know there was no condolences
or nothing
you know and that kind that shook me man
like
my friend passed away and he's like oh
do you wanna you wanna go pee
you think cause
like what what about looking at me makes
you think cause my friend is gone
that I want to pay that I want to go
hold my wiener in a small room and have
water come out of it you know
I mean we're just losing touch with each
other man
but yeah for about 20 25 minutes
um
I thought he was deceased and uh and
then I get a text from Will
and um
and he said hey man uh we're just joking
or whatever we just had burritos or
something like that you know some
just typical you know just real Sig app
just some real Sig app [ __ ] or whatever
you know
but anyway [ __ ] we haven't even gotten
it I've just been rambling guys
[Music]
um
we had some great voicemails that came
in you know it's just I feel I feel I I
want to say I I
um
I'll do I want to do more solo episodes
I want to be able to keep the our
connection uh sometimes it's been I've
been just managing like what's he what
is most capable for me and so um
so if you wonder like man Theo doesn't
do it this week it's not that I don't
care
it's just that's
um what I can like handle for myself
so I have to make sure I take care of uh
of myself
you know I've been caught up for years I
got caught up
trying to do everything
and
um
man and it really really burned me out
it burned my dick open
so now I'm just managing things a little
bit I'm managing myself you know because
I want to be able to be alive
[Music]
um
and and I'm excited next year we're
gonna add up we're gonna add back in
some elements of trying to do some
positive things for people
um we were we're just we're getting
things back on track here
and um
and that's awesome
that's awesome uh some great
some great calls came in let me get to
him here was there any news let me see
there is a light
I like that
musk restores Trump's Twitter account
after online poll you know what's funny
about Elon Musk people forget his last
name is Musk
because musk is just that damn that's
your damn what is it let me look it up
m-u-s
K Musk
damn
and it's funny now you put musk the
definite if you put Musk
he comes up but when I was growing up
musk it was just uh
a strong smelling reddish brown
substance which is secreted by the male
musk deer for scent marking and it is an
important degree the gradient in
perfumery
so musk is just that body bust you know
it's that damn it's just when your damn
pours all kind of fart just and sheer
just this is who I am baby it's that you
know it's the uh license and
registration of your [ __ ] soul baby
you know it's your it's your just your
essence just [ __ ] busting a damn air
nut into people's nostrils baby that's
what musk is
you got that musk baby damn
that musk boy that's why you see a dog
gotta go get a hit of another dog or
another animal's ass bro they want that
you know that's that damn business card
baby
that's the devil's business card baby
your [ __ ]
and that's why you see a dog go over
there and just try to get another dog's
number real quick
he just you know just gets that hit
you get all the information at once you
know
it's like Larry Plummer
601 4460 you know it's like damn
that's it baby
that's Mother Nature's QR code baby that
that b-hole
you get that information
people hit you with that you pull that
Intel off somebody's backside off that
b-hole
there is a light and Shining for me
one day off of vaping baby
I am right now one full day off of
vaping and I'm gonna try to keep going
my God is it hard
but yeah Elon beat out damn Deer uh
deer bust so it's interesting
when you know another case of humans
just out uh just defeating nature in the
sense that what we think is important
you know musk used to be the damn sense
of the animal
and now it's some [ __ ] dude that's
afraid of the Sun
but I do love seeing him make people at
Twitter squirm I like anybody but get
the squirm on them
Twitter has been Twitter nothing I I
feel I mean the internet so cell phones
have killing us uh Twitter nothing has
been worse than Twitter
it's trash
it's trash man
and it's not open it's not open sore you
can't just say what it's like they let
me you can say you can say you can say
you can't say it just even it out maybe
make it a Royal Rumble that's all I'm
saying
make it make it either these are the
rules or these aren't the rules
but some people shouldn't get the rules
and other people not get the rules
because in those aren't rules those are
damn
cages
what else do we got
oh Buffalo got hit with this blizzard
baby I don't know if you've seen this
and if you're in recovery baby there's
nothing like seeing a damn blizzard hit
a bunch of people
my God
there's nothing like seeing that when
the Skies open up and serve that that 30
ball to the world hit that two that 200
ball
you got a damn half of the suburbs
just damn hopped up on us on a 2000 ball
on a on a on a four on a 60 70 ball you
got a 80 ball in the damn driveway
you're out there
I loved it man
Dawson Knox was sending me pictures AJ
Klein was sending me pictures
God I was I I don't think that the
players
um and the people of Buffalo know just
the damn just
I mean just that temperature porn that's
what I was on God
I see a driveway I see a shovel
I'm musking baby I can feel my damn my
chest just go from a damn lowercase a
cup to a [ __ ]
two up to almost a half a
just I could feel myself just half a and
in my chest
I think though we were all hopped up
when but when Buffalo shared those snow
pictures God we were all there now I was
in the comfort of my warm home
you know
but I swear to God I went and made me
some damn hot choke a lot and honoring
him in honor of those good folks
um you gotta love the bills it's
exciting and I'll tell you why it's
exciting because those fans that that
that's fan Hood
that's for you out there you take your
family to the game you damn lose a
family member
everybody in that [ __ ] you know the
inside of the stadium looks like home
alone on a Tuesday because they got 90
kids and people adults McAlister's
everybody's stuck in that [ __ ] people
just hitting each other in the face but
damn uh
shaving cream lotion and running around
and putting thumb tacks on the stairs
people damn home alone and up and down
but that's how the bills go
what is it Ralph Waldo
whatever it is Ralph Emerson Stadium
you'll be out there damn you get a text
from work you're a boss sit down stuck
in Ralph Emerson Stadium
I've been in that [ __ ] you know
I've been in this [ __ ] since we beat
the Ravens since we beat Edgar Allan Poe
you know
but damn I was loving that that made my
that really made that was a nice time
for the weekend
oh I went to UFC 281 sorry I just feel
like I'm just bragging now kinda
yeah I I just feel like I'm bragging
um but dude that was so much fun
man when I go into the UFC things man
for me I really it's like
sleigh bells ring while you're listening
children's slings
um children slings uh
I don't know the rest of it but it's
like I think it's about like
like a bunch of kids broke their arms or
whatever you know what song I'm talking
about
um God it's just good
you know it just man when I'm in there
it's like every fighter that I see is
like one of the reindeer and like Dana
White is like Santa
and it just
everything about it's just like
and then the music starts and then the
fighters come out and they're all
Warriors
you know they're all so it's like you
y'all are doing something so many of us
can't couldn't do
um
yeah there's just so much about it
and I was sitting there watching it was
uh Dave portnoy's and his buddy big cat
and they were I mean they were cheering
for Molly my cans baby
and she I mean this lady had Molly
McCain's in a damn crucifix I mean I
don't know if you saw the Molly McCann's
fight
and they had her in that damn cruise I
mean this uh who did she fight
Molly mccanns
and she's British she's a skaiuza
and you know I like she got that Rough
and Tumble baby you know what I'm saying
she got that girl in her
she got to look like her vagina would
arm wrestle you a little you know she's
got that her thumb wrestle at least baby
she's got that gumption she's uh
she's a warrior
you know and she fought
um
she fought and she didn't get the win
and the girl she fought Archibald who
was the lady she fought I think Aaron
Archibald Aaron Blanche of Blanche field
and it was just about I mean I'd love to
see that fight again it was it was
amazing but I mean she had McCann she
had her in this in the crucifix you know
she had her damn I mean she had her in
the damn third Testament
to be honest she really had her
you know but Molly did not I mean she
was like gosh
she was like one of those door-to-door
salesmen that's just like
I mean she [ __ ] Kevin I mean knock knock
knock knock knock knock knock she just
would I mean [ __ ] oh it's powerful
when you're sitting there watching women
do that and you know you couldn't even
do it
dude I'd have tapped brought a tap
man if I have to sneeze into my hand
real hard and there's no Kleenex bro
I'll tap I've tapped out of a hard
sneeze dude just because the pressure
sometimes it puts on my neck duh
you know damn you get a little bit of
light Whiplash and I'm out baby
I just lost to sinuses
um
but that was great to be at the fights
it was just
I mean it just was magical
and people were bombed went out of Sonya
lost
but also you know it's all like the you
know it's just the story of how things
go
um
and then Poirier and Chandler you know I
I like both of these they're both
they're both totally different guys
um but both just great guys I don't
think anybody wanted to see them fight
each other except them
um but that was in an unbelievable fight
in the first round I was like who's
everybody like
I felt like we all everybody won
everybody it just like was
them thing everybody was uncut it was
just
I felt like people were I felt like
there was a minute where they were both
unconscious but also fighting
so just just wow man and then the ring
girls man where they are dang every time
they come around the ring I'm like all
right
uh yes I do
I do
dearly beloved that's all I hear every
time they go walking by we are gathered
here I do yes
oh I would be honored that's what I just
that's how I feel when they go by
um yeah this was some of the stuff from
the Buffalo Bills blizzard this stuff
was great man
uh
uh and this blizzard I mean this looks
like
wow if you can see this I mean it looks
like Colombia
took a vacation
so fun people just diving into people
disappearing a lot of people probably
gonna
I don't want to say I'm sure a dateline
episode will start from this a lot of
people getting rid of their wives or
whatever
a lot of lesbianism starts also in cold
weather you know that
go talk to a lesbian
they'll tell you
that's a cold weather sport huh
let me get you out of that coat huh
and let me get you into a little bit of
a little bit of this non-weiner
that's what they're that's how it starts
right there
it's a gateway drug for lesbianism
Chinese man runs a marathon while chain
smoking yeah
yeah
Chinese people they do everything while
chain smoking if you've been to China or
not
or if you've been this where they build
everything
you get you pick up anything now in a
store you smell it you can smell a
little bit of chain smoking in it
it doesn't matter what it is you get any
get you a little uh thing of uh
a little thing of um shirts or
undershorts Hanes undershorts you smell
it's like damn somebody been smoking in
these [ __ ]
or you get you a lamp shade that [ __ ]
already got smoke in it damn
this thing got half a Winston built into
the fabric
but that's China they blowing smoke in
everything
our silverware everything probably has
uh carcinogens in it
um
what else do we have
construction worker destroys business
after they don't pay them hell yeah
I like that
let's see what happened this dude
oh yeah
he didn't get paid baby he's taking the
work back
I love it
I love this
dang he's eating the walls with that
little uh
that little motor Hammer whatever that
thing is that little uh T-Rex that thing
looks like a damn T-Rex but it's a just
a machine
man that thing will [ __ ] huh that
thing's beautiful
um but yeah this guy you can't see the
video he's brought a little
um shoveler it's like a little motorized
shoveler
have like a big shovel when he drives it
and he's just basically attacking the
walls in this building I love this and
I'll tell you why
because this is where we're at man
this is where we're at if you got
insurance you're covered
and somebody get you down like that they
don't do you get a do what you got to do
baby
and this is one thing that I miss about
and honestly I miss a little about uh
being young being completely broke
having nothing
because when you got nothing
they can't they can't take nothing from
you
that's when you're the freest you could
ever be
they go on you free as can be you got
nothing then they can't take nothing
from you
you could say do what you ain't got no
because you know what happens is you if
you we have something they say something
people sue you
they come out they trick you they trick
everybody they'll find a way
so then you're like dang I want to say
something but I like this having this
new this sofa
you know I want to say something but I
got a damn microwave of it there I got a
damn lava lamp
I got a damn microwave that work that
runs in conjunction with my lava lamp
I'm making a damn TV dinner and I got a
bunch of a little some goop over here
doing a damn Dougie in a in the in the
and the lamp
you know
so I don't know what I'm talking about
but
but that's the time baby
[ __ ] you got nothing get out there
because let him you know who's not
they're not gonna sue you if you got
nothing
they ain't gonna see because you ain't
there ain't nothing so you the winner
that's a lawsuit Universe now it's
Insurance Nation baby a teen solo hiker
who was terrorized for Days by unknown
figures dressed in white
two cops who quit their job at a local
theater because of unexplained
encounters with an alleged demon
and isolated forest in Canada where
people keep turning up headless
these are just some of the strange dark
and mysterious stories you'll hear each
week on the Mr Ballin podcast in each
episode Mr Ballin shares real-life
haunting accounts like the case of Haley
zaga who disappeared from a hiking trail
for 51 hours
that's right if you like the mystery and
Intrigue you want to know what could be
going on
Mr Ballin
could have it for you hey Prime members
listen to the Amazon music exclusive
podcast Mr Ballin podcast strange dark
and mysterious stories in the Amazon
music app download the app today
all right let's get into some voicemails
man you guys have uh been so patient and
I'm sorry this I thought this would be a
shorter episode because I just wanted to
do happy holidays
um
but here we go uh
let's take a call right here
hi Theo um
Borneo
hey Megan
hey Megan
onward
um I'm a new fan probably like the last
six months
watching a bunch of your podcasts and
different interviews you've been on
Bobby Lee I love Bobby Lee too
um I'm a single mom and I've been dating
a little bit and I just wanted to let
you know that good for you baby to get
out there
you know get out there we all have to
get out there this is our time
you know I I use so much of my life when
I look at the past of my life I was
afraid to get out there because I don't
look the way I want to look I don't you
know I'm I'm not in my best shape right
now I'm not
but then damn as life goes on it's it
all just gets a little tougher and you
never get to this space the perfect
space
so the whole time I'm keeping myself
away from Joy away from possibility
because I just uh out of fear a lot of
times or insecurity I did that a lot I'm
not accusing you of that it just
man when I look at pictures of myself
even a few years ago I say damn man
I wish you'd have more confidence then
you know I wish you went and did the you
know
but that's okay
um because I I can try now
um but I'm glad you're getting out there
man let's hear more
I wasn't doing okay dating before like I
think I'm attractive I'm not sure
um but once I told guys like oh yeah I
like Theo Vaughn I've been getting so
much more dick
before
and then before
um you guys just love it I mean what
um
hey
we give him back to these single moms
boys
look I'm glad it sounded like you've
been getting safely poked out there you
know hopefully you don't look like MGK's
uh VMAs outfit
um
but
um that's good for you I'm glad you're
getting some decent wiener out there on
behalf of the community baby
and that's what we do out there we serve
semi-decent to decent wiener
you know if you want something outside
of that you're gonna have to go
elsewhere but that's what we serve
praise God baby I'm happy you're doing
well and you stay busy out there and get
that wand mama get you a little bit of
that Thanksgiving wand huh get a little
bit of a little bit of root meat with
your turkey huh
what else we got a couple other calls
have came in uh
um
here we got one right here what's up
Theo so I just had a question oh right I
just found out like a couple months ago
that like my dad isn't like my actual
dad and my mom has just been like
straight up lying for like 18 years to
my face and like I found it out because
I was getting documents for like college
and I was like just like medical [ __ ]
and like I said the name and all my
dad's name it was like different and so
I got on my mom and I'm like yo like why
is it different she goes oh it must be
like a typo or like they messed it up or
some [ __ ] and I was like oh all right
then and then so my friend called me
like a week later and he goes yeah bro
your mom got drunk and told my mom that
you're not your dad's son and I was like
yo what the [ __ ] and so like I go on a
trip whoa so dude I feel like the clues
are adding up kind of a little I'm sorry
to hear this
that you're not the dad's son you are
not the son
you are not the son
the dad's like
um but bro you are you at the beach or
something because it's you're like bro
my dad you know he didn't know and I
told my mom she's like what
what and then I feel like I'm talking to
Chad and JT this could be a Chad and JT
prank
um but I'm a rod imma ride let's hear
more
and I'm sorry I'm well I don't I can't
tell how this is affecting you yet it's
like my cousins and [ __ ] and I'm I open
up to him I'm like yo I don't think my
dad is my real dad and they go yeah we
know that we then knew that and like
everyone in my whole life knew
bro
are you sure you didn't are you sure
it sounds like
you should have known I hate to say that
but
it sounds like everybody like hey this
isn't my real dad and people are like no
[ __ ]
Carl or whatever you know or Richard let
me hear the beginning name sorry what's
up Theo so I just had a question so oh
you didn't have a name yeah what oh no I
mean was there moments where you were
like
where you've got like a Christmas
present from him and it was like
um
two my son love Dad question mark
like did anything like that ever happen
or were you ever in the house and you
were like Dad
and he was like not it like did you did
you hear any memories because
it just sound you're like Mom it's not
our real dad and she's like I don't know
Bob might be a typo I mean is are you
guys eating weed or something let's hear
more
and like everyone in my whole life knew
everyone knew and no one told me my mom
ever lying to me and I just didn't talk
to her for days and I'm just like for
days bro this whole thing I think this
is Chad and JT and if it is dude
uh
you that's pretty good man we didn't you
know I almost like it's in your dad man
and I was like uh
[Applause]
oh
if it's not brother if this is not as
pranked and I am I am sorry I'm sorry
but also you got a new adventure baby
you out there
you know
you got the you're that [ __ ] Sherlock
homie bro you out there you could go
[ __ ] get you a new dad find that new
you know that and this day it could be a
you know you got a chance to really it's
almost like I'll trade what's that
what's here but you know it's like Let's
Make a Deal
all right Ron or whatever I'll give you
you know I'll give you you know uh Alan
or whatever the dad's name is and I'll
take a chance for what's behind door
number seven or whatever so good luck
out there bro a lot of us you know you
get the dad you get and you don't get
that second opportunity so this could be
God really doing something powerful for
you
and I think you got to pay attention too
bro it sounds like people been trying to
tell you it was on your birth
certificate your cousin's all new people
were shocked when you didn't know
I think you got to drop in dude and look
at just some baby pictures and stuff and
see who
the man is that's next to your mom
and I think
it's gonna blow your mind dude
praise brother let's hear another call
that came in here
um
[Music]
here we go
hey to you my name is Noah I'm just
basically calling to let you know that
uh a lot of what you say is pretty much
exactly how I feel man uh when you talk
about being addicted to your emotions I
completely understand that I feel the
exact same way I'm in recovery also and
I'm 57 days sober today and uh my man
congratulations bro
57 days How how Wild is that
you know you know how no you know how
few people in the world have ever done
anything for 57 days
especially giving up something we liked
dude it's hard
it's it's I'm one day off vaping right
now bro
and I want to [ __ ] smoke a bowl out
of my own nuts bruh pure nicotine
so it's really magical man to see you
having this these 57 days man
onward this [ __ ] just gets overwhelming
sometimes man you know I thought getting
server would solve most of my problems
but I guess Life's a little bit more
complicated than that
now if I was carried around this anger
with me that I can't really put my
finger on you know just the littlest
things will set me off like dropping
something or bumping into something I'll
be screaming in my head for for hours
oh man I can really relate to that
if there's an inanimate object I can
tell how I'm doing right in the morning
I bump into something on the way out of
my room
and
I used to be that I'd be so angry
August [ __ ] yeah I'll burn you I
will burn you
I will put you in a fireplace
you know I'll just yelled at it pieces
of furniture
but now you know what I noticed the
other day I'm able
sometimes I'll go
I'm able to laugh because I don't see
that the fact that I bumped into
something I don't see it as any
reflection of who I am
or any reflection that the world is
trying to get me
or the world is angry at me
and I only say that just to say that uh
there it it can those feelings of anger
you still have it can adjust
uh let's hear more now I'd like to say
that if if someone else spoke to me the
way that I speak to myself you know I'd
have to kill that son of a [ __ ] because
you know I couldn't tolerate that
I don't know why we're just so mean to
ourselves man
you know I get I don't know why I get so
addicted to things you know I'm even
addicted to damn nasal spray
you know that's about the hardest thing
I've had to kick to be honest with you
um
man I appreciate your honesty here uh
yeah look I had a non-addict I had a
non-addictive nasal spray that I had for
a while that
um I sometimes I pull up if I was going
to a bar or something I'd do a hitting
each nose before I go in it didn't even
do anything to me
it gave me a little bit of a flashback
of probably doing a drug or something
you know and just kind of heightened my
senses in a weird way or
[Music]
um
but yeah man I I'm sorry that you are so
mean to yourself
you know and I don't mean that as a
reflection of who uh who you are because
I know
like me you don't want to be
you know you don't want to be
um
but if you're like us you have some of
this that we have this
ISM this alcoholism this
this uncomfort it's really an uncomfort
that just lives in US
[Music]
um
yeah you're probably gonna be real hard
on yourself
you know I think I was always extremely
hard that's the number one note people
have given me
now you're so hard on yourself
and I think I used to think that if I
wasn't hard on myself
then nobody was let me think about this
if I wasn't hard on myself
because when I was young nobody was
anything on me you know
and so I realized I thought maybe if I
was hard on myself or maybe if I was
perfect
you know I used to think I realized this
the other day I used to think that uh
well I expected myself to be perfect so
then I would never was because it's
impossible so then therefore I'm so hard
on myself
you know
because I thought that I I wasn't
cared for as a child and I'm not trying
to self-pity I'm just looking at what
was a part of my life
that
I wasn't cared for as a child so
therefore I took it on myself oh if I
was better
if I was perfect
then I would be loved you know I'm not
perfect enough
I'm not good enough
you know I'm not good enough for my
mother to see me I'm not good enough
um
for my father to stay alive I had this
Epiphany not long ago that I thought
that if I
was better
if I was perfect if I did everything
right as a kid I thought this I didn't
know until just recently that I thought
it but it came up
that if I did everything right that my
father would stay alive
that's what I thought for some reason as
a kid I
you know nobody explained to me what was
going on or how things worked or that
that was getting you know I just knew my
dad was older and that he was not going
to be alive for a long time and as a
child I thought maybe if I'm perfect
if I'm perfect you know
that my life would be different
you know and more specifically that my
dad would stay alive I thought that I
don't know how I came up with that or
what made me think that as a kid
but at least then it gave me some
control over what or what was going to
happen
because
now it's some of it's something it's up
to me
you know even though it's not realistic
it's impossible for that to come to
fruition but it's up to me then
so that's why I think I was so hard on
myself a lot of times I think because
then at least it
it puts it on me
which was the only thing that I felt I
could try and rely on anyway
um because I didn't feel comfortable in
the world
um
and that's not some down I'm not trying
to down or anybody uh
uh but I thought about that let's hear
more brother thanks for the call yeah
there's another picture for me man I
just wanted to tell you things and that
you want to learn man you know there's a
ton of days where your podcast is the
only time I smiled that day so
keep doing the Lord's work man take care
of yourself again
thanks bro
you too man you know I'm proud of you
dude it's hard uh you know
um
I'm proud of you
I'm proud of you because I know how hard
it is to take care of ourselves
you know I know how hard it is to take
care of ourselves I know that um
for me uh I never wanted to take care of
myself because if I took care of myself
then uh
that I was doing somebody else's job
instead I wanted to show I just always
wanted to show you how much I was
hurting you know
um
and so starting to take care of myself
was doing the opposite of that
and it was the opposite of the whole
thing that I had like oh you're gonna
see him when you look at me you're gonna
see how much I hurt
you know
um and starting to take care of myself
as a total opposite of that so I hear
that in you today and I'm I'm thankful
for that man I really am and I'm
grateful that I have moments like this
these are moments that mean something to
me you know two guys being trying to be
honest
and not even being gay and just being
honest
um because these are moments I never had
as a child I never had there was never
any peace in my house there was never a
chance for anybody even to listen or to
be heard
there was never even any piece of space
to think or to feel there was no space
for that
and uh
and so it's moments like this you know
where I can have an honest conversation
with somebody
I'd have given anything if you know to
have these as a child and children need
these sort of things
um so anyway bro yeah enough [ __ ]
enough of that [ __ ] for me too bro but
praise man I'm happy for you and uh
Happy Thanksgiving man you made my day
you really did brother praise God
uh let's hear what else we got man
um
and don't get don't give up dog stay in
there 57 man stay in there baby
uh
uh let me see
here we go
hey deal what's up man this is Robert
calling out of Fort Worth what's up
Robert out of Fort Worth baby I love
Texas
it's a good place and
um that's great man Fort Worth I've been
down there I used to go down there to
Randy Butler's Comedy Room one of my
favorite comedy rooms I used to have
down there can't remember the name of it
offhand
but um
God he had probably the best I mean he
might have the best comedy room in the
country when they used to have it it was
underground over there in Fort Worth
and you could get your little comedy on
there and get you a little liquor and
even get your little leg or a little
titty sometime afterwards out there meet
you some modding praise God brother
onward a big fan uh anyways well I have
a question man and I know you have a lot
of Comedy stuff a lot of funny stuff
which I watch for but I have like a
serious person okay so here it is so me
and my fiance we've been together for
about six months seven months and uh
well she has some court dates coming up
and she's facing some time she's facing
about eight years now I don't know if I
should I mean I really don't know what I
should do should I should I break it off
before she goes or should I wait for her
for eight years or or what should I do
man I mean I really really love her
she's a really good woman and we have a
lot of good times together man but you
know I'm a man and not only because I
have needs because it's not even about
that it's just about the you know I mean
that's a long time to wait I mean she
might not do a full eight we should
probably do I don't know maybe two three
four five years bang Debbie gang baby
crime you know
and this is this is a crime call
you know and this is where hopefully she
got with Morgan and Morgan over there
they do good attorney work
I don't know who she got getting her the
years or getting out of her whatever but
um
uh
I'll say this man first of all how the
times have changed
this is a call you would hear during war
war one
World War II World War III
when people
win wives their husband going off to
military or they're in A POW Camp what
do I do they call in
you know on the ring phone in the D you
know what do I do do I wait for Andy
do I wait for Ricardo
I mean look it depends on what type of
life you want to lead
There's Something Beautiful about
waiting for someone
there's something romantic about it
there's something really perfect about
because you get to keep them in this
space in your head where they're perfect
they can't really do any wrong because
they don't have to it's almost sometimes
waiting for somebody can be a sense of
control
I'm gonna wait for you but really what
I'm doing not all the time
but really what I'm doing is I'm going
to say I'm going to keep this in a
perfect place where it's manageable
because I don't really have to interact
with it
it's almost like something I can just
keep on the shelf right here I can
communicate with it when I need to I can
get what I need from it
in some ways I have somebody to care
about but I don't physically have to
have them there
I'm not saying you're doing that I'm
saying I've done that in my life in
relationships
um
but damn dude but then also you're gonna
have to do them conjugal visits or
whatever or you have to sneak over there
at night and just Andy do fraying your
weiner through that chain link fence
and let uh your girl let Molly or
whatever her name is over there not you
know knobby off over there for the
spotlight hits you
because I can't ejaculate under a sheer
Spotlight anything over probably
120 watts buddy I can't come you know
and that's who I am
but if there's a strong if a you know if
I'm getting an HJ and a boat pulls up or
something you know or
uh
or if they have two even two coal miners
walk up while I'm getting a handy bro I
can't
I can't eat Jack around more than
probably about 120 watts
of straight light
so
but that's me you know that's me and I
think it's Brave now then how far do you
want to go
do you want to make her stuff and mail
her things do you want to have an apron
also because I'm sure there's a whole
club of men
who love prison women let me look it up
men who love prison women
couldn't oh
um
let me see husbands of in prison
women
they kill their husbands now in prison
that's not you man because you're
calling in
[Music]
um
I don't know I get it you know you I'm
sure you could get some information
about this uh but look I think it's
admirable of you
you know man used to go off to War and
the women would wait for him
you know and I think if you're baby
birds over there in prison
you know and you you can keep your seed
in the feeder
then yeah you can wait till she gets out
you know
and then also you may be able to set up
a situation with her where you say look
I'm gonna I'm gonna date
I love you and this is I'm gonna date
you while you're there so then at least
you also can be honest with her in case
you want to date outside of there you
give yourself the opportunity to still
fall in love you know
um
because then you don't want to have a
thing I don't think where you're
cheating and having to lie about it
that's this that's when you're skating
on dirty ice baby but praise brother I
hope you uh you know I think it's really
kind of you to even think about that and
I think it shows some awareness for who
you are as a person and I think
as long as you're honest with her about
what you're thinking bro that's really
going to be nice you know and so bless
you man and good luck over there
um
let me see
let's see here what else we got
Andrew he's from Brisbane how you going
um hey Andrew from Brisbane how you
going mister
I've always wanted to call in with
something funny you know like like the
rest of them or something interesting
but I'll listen to your podcast and
you're saying you don't have to call in
with something interesting
um you just call up with you know what
you do for a living so I'm a Milkman I
deliver the milk around Brisbane uh
start work at around two o'clock in the
morning
bruh
thank you for calling Andrew
um
any milk man that's working at 2 A.M
bruh
I'm you know what I'm saying we both
know what you doing baby
you know
you said you got that slinging that body
milk son
that [ __ ] blue percent you know what
I'm talking about dude you out there
balling out in people's Gardens let's
hear more and I finish around 11 o'clock
so I've got the whole day to be at home
and um you know I love it and also I
guess that's perfect why that's probably
why they blame the Milkman because you
know I'm at home all afternoon while the
rest of the blokes are at work working
hard so
um Big Ups big love Theo love your show
praise brother thank you for calling
Australia I don't even know you I mean I
guess yeah I never even thought about
y'all having milk over there
but I guess it makes sense y'all would
have milk
um but damn if let me tell you bro if
you rolling up at somebody's house with
a couple of jugs baby
at 2 A.M dude
that's
you a pervert bro
you a pervert man
and I you know I think this is God
talking through me right now
I mean damn expect like [ __ ] I don't
know man maybe I'm being too mean to you
but I just
maybe I don't know maybe there's
something nice about it
you out there this damn [ __ ] leaving
people a little bit of yogurt bruh you
out there girton on people gurting and
you know just right you know leave a
little canister a girt by the door
you out there gerting for Mom gurting
for Dad or whatever
I mean damn I don't know
I remember the first time I ever even
had a little bit of yogurt bro I thought
damn
somebody's gay bruh you know not me but
whoever's making it or whatever
somewhere along the chain of command
somebody's gate out or something on this
because how else they even doing is
putting all of you know
it was
um
strawberry so but good luck over there
bro stay alive God bless you Australia I
cannot wait to come there I'm looking to
make a trip uh next I believe
Thanksgiving Before Christmas to have
like a time over there in us to do a few
weeks and do some shows maybe sooner but
I want to come I think in the summer I
guess I don't know what's the best time
to come let me know
um
as well we're looking to hire uh
somebody who works in videography Clips
uh making good social clips and that
sort of thing
um you can send a DM to the uh uh this
past weekend producer
um Instagram account that's the way to
do that
let's get one more call here what do we
have
let's go bro
Marco over here in Las Vegas hey I'm a
new new podcast fan I've seen specials
and all but I didn't know you had a
podcast well I'm sure you did but I just
remember that and uh you know I've been
binge watching you know it's October all
the way back in February and I was just
the one where you're talking about your
feelings and your mom and you know I
just want to ask how you doing with that
like how you feeling how's how's life
been treating you how's your
relationship you know how's the
I know that Ayahuasca helped you out
have seen some things and steal some
things
um but you know I just want to see how
you feeling man I really appreciate the
podcast I appreciate everything you do
um the way you talk to us you know even
though you know I really talked to it
but I feel like you're talking to us you
know praise God gang gang gang baby
thank you thank you for the question man
uh this kind of stuff yeah you know I
love thinking about that this type of
thing and
um yeah the Ayahuasca was very helpful
it was tough going through all that I
mean it's great it's a grueling thing
it's just until you've gone through it
and really done it is I mean it's
it's a lot on your body it's basically
it's a damn I mean you it's you're out
there in uh
you know it's like buds for your
emotions
you know you're doing a lot
um
yeah I'm still kind of getting uh a
little bit more clarity on some of it
but it's amazing how over time it gets
clearer
and how over time it's still uh helps me
um
I'm so grateful for that experience I'm
[Music]
um
you know
yeah I didn't get what I needed as a kid
I didn't get it
I didn't get it
and
you know I realized I've had a tough
time growing up in my life I'm a late
bloomer
and that's okay
I had a really tough time growing up in
my life
[Music]
um
you know and when I was young when I was
a kid you know my dad wasn't around my
uh and my dad was very old and my mother
worked and my mother had sort of an
emotional condition where she couldn't
um
she didn't look at me a lot and she
didn't uh
um
she didn't come like come to me if I if
I was hurt if I was like physically hurt
then she would react but if I was just
like had some emotional pain or she my
mother wouldn't come to me she had a
tough time putting her hands on me
um
so that was just how things were right I
did you know that was that's that's okay
um it's not okay but that was life
um
but I realized as an adult uh that I
never wanted to grow up
I never wanted to grow up I was a late
bloomer and I didn't want to grow up and
I I realized why
because I still wanted to be that kid
because if I grow up
I still wanted to be that kid I still
wanted my mother to come around my you
know I still was waiting on these things
that I didn't get as a child
and I was waiting and ever since I could
I was I was trying to stay as young as I
could and be and
because once I evolved once I become an
adult that kid doesn't even exist
anymore and he doesn't exist anyway but
I there's something inside of me it's
like if I can just if I can just
not grow up then I'll be able to still
be this kid and I'll and whenever the
things come in that I needed I'll be
here to get them
but that was never going to happen
and at a certain point me just to stay
in a child forever was uh it was just
robbing me of becoming an adult
um
and man it's really hard to let go uh
it's really hard to let go and grow up
because I'm the last because once I do
that there's no that kid doesn't even
know he's not even there anymore
I mean he's still there deep inside of
me but he's not like
they're waiting
you know um
and I'm not saying this I don't need any
self-pity I'm okay with this I have some
feelings around it you know it's a
little bit emotional for me to think
about
um
yeah I don't know
there's there's more in it and I'll
think about some more of it and talk
about it more in the future
um
but
but yeah if I didn't have that Ayahuasca
I would never have gotten that
understanding
I would have never gotten under the
understanding that uh
I'm still waiting there's so much of me
that's still just a child waiting for
what he was supposed to get as a kid
um because I couldn't figure it out
I couldn't get any I couldn't get a look
at myself
I couldn't get a step back from me to
see me enough
to say okay here's what's going on and
Ayahuasca really helped me man it gives
you
you can look it through yourself through
a microscope or you could look through
binoculars and you can do it all at the
same time and so that was a real gift
um
and uh yeah okay what's up let me get
some something more for you guys man
this has been a lot about me and I'm
sorry about that
um oh we got a miracle this fella had
coldie you know he'd lost his uh he'd
jump on a bomb in the war
and um we were talking about having him
on as a as a one of our Miracle guests
and let's hear a little more he called
back
y baby
uh just listen to this most recent uh
solo episode dog and he mentioned me
um I sincerely appreciate you brother
sincerely dude uh iwamente brother thank
you thanks for everything man
um
and yeah man I I did serve in the Marine
Corps from uh 2007 to 2013. obviously I
had to get out because of my leg
situation oh sorry to laugh I think you
made me laugh for uh onward
um but yeah man I don't know I'd take a
one-legged Marine bro a lot of times
over [ __ ] some of these cats is it
that's it that's in somebody's Choice
bro
I take a damn dude I would take a
[ __ ] two-armed Marine if he's walking
on his arms bruh and he could shoot a
gun with his with his dick I [ __ ] that
dude could run it bro gang
uh much love and respect you can call me
at 209. okay great and I'll stop it
right there you thought we were gonna
leave your number out there that would
have been bad
um man you know I think it's a great
place to to pull the episode over to the
side because you know just to hear the
joy the the ability in your voice to
have some Joy man when you've had such
an experience you know
such an experience man of sacrifice and
of um
I'm sure of adjustment and of ways to
find gratitude now uh which are all
things that I think we will talk about
you we'll reach out and we'll get it
done we'll get you on there uh and then
in the coming um we get another solo
episode we'll put you on it man so we'll
figure that out
uh if you know a miracle or someone or
you are a miracle of somebody
um
985-664-9503 uh if there's something
going on you're struggling with hit the
hotline as well look sometimes it might
take a year to hear back from us
sometimes you might never hear back
um we do what we can
uh we're gonna try to work on it more in
the new year
um about just having maybe somebody on
board that that is their job
to help moderate uh because
you know we're still figuring it all out
um
and look I'm a late bloomer baby when it
comes to everything even with business I
didn't want anybody to help me for years
I couldn't let anybody help me and now I
know I need help
you know I need help on the outside I
need help on the inside
and that's okay man uh
but thank you
thank you uh Marine I don't know if
that's a sergeant No Marina corporal
thank you Maureen
uh for your
uh sacrifice and
um
and for your attitude even just in that
call man
I can hear you excited you could you
know
that's cool and that's the power of each
other because I I hear you say that man
and it makes me feel man here's
um here's a man who has probably who was
a really
capable man I mean Marines are
physically capable men
you know who lost something who lost a
day you know who lost something and
can't do as much physical anymore
and he's finding ways man
you know he's finding ways to have pride
and uh and to keep his life going on
powerfully
um just gives us all a lot to be
thankful for and thankful for you
um and anybody who serves
uh and if you just serve your family as
a father
if you serve your nieces and nephews as
a uncle or an aunt
if you serve your spouse
because they're going through a tough
time
and you get home a few minutes early
and instead of jumping on the couch you
make them a cookie or you write them a
little note
if you serve your higher power
where you hit your knees and you say hey
I need some help
or sometimes I'll just I like to
sometimes now just
I like praying for other people that's
important in my life
because I'm not it's not really a
religious thing it's just me thinking
about them
and not thinking about me
we got a lot to be thankful for baby
praise God
and uh I love you guys thank you so much
for being a part of my life
um I feel so grateful to be able to be
here today and to be able to just try
and speak honestly
um we live in a world where and in a
society especially in America where uh
there's a lot of
um caps on if you can communicate
honestly or not or even question things
[Music]
um
and we'll try our best to do what we can
and uh
and that's okay
but you guys be good to yourselves man
you deserve it
um
I know you do
I know you do and uh
what else dang I don't know I thought we
should have got into more funny stuff
but we tried our best and that's okay
let's go out the way that we rolled into
this bad cat baby you know who it is
right here I got them for you
um
gang
[Music]
I know you've heard it before
a lady sent me a video of her kids
singing this yesterday man
it was cool
I'm just sitting on your front porch
wondering how could I be so far
[Music]
and my mind is somewhere else but when I
found it I'll patch up with this man
long
Travis McCready
[Music]
Happy Thanksgiving guys
[Music]
Happy Thanksgiving Make It Count
[Music]
hug somebody hold that hug hold the line
with it
feel it in my bones
[Music]
break
let myself on my arm
s
[Music]
I'll sit and tell you my story
[Music]
on the song I will sing it just for you
that's it baby you guys be good to
yourself Happy Thanksgiving we'll be
back next week with um
uh Neil Degrassi Tyson and he's the
space baby you know he's that tall space
baby dang you know he's that damn it
looked at a ladder and said nah [ __ ] I
want more so uh intrigued to have him
back and intrigued to have you back hit
the hotline 95
664-9503 and um that's it gang